[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous et bon livre
nous arrivons au mois de novembre donc
proche de noël donc faut penser aux
cadeaux de noël les livres sont quelques
un cadeau intéressant mais il y aura les
salons bientôt qui arrive salon de
rambouillet 17 novembre salon
d'elancourt le 24 novembre notamment et
la lecture c est un acte est un acte de
résistance chaque lecture est un acte de
résistance dit daniel pennac une lecture
bien mené sauf de tout y compris que
semaine alors essayons de résister et de
nous sauver
alors nous allons débuter cette émission
avec suzy mal très inquiets présidente
du salon de rambouillet président de
l'association awalet poète romancière et
nouvelliste et qui va nous parler de de
maupassant au comptant je vais vous
parler de maupassant maupassant trois
vies de florence lisez aux éditions in
octavo c'est un voyage au pays de caux
en septembre 1893 et une rencontre dans
son manoir entre lors la mère de guy
paquet de guy de maupassant
joséphine lise hellman mère de trois
enfants de l'écrivain et une amende
elles se parlent s'affrontent dresse un
portrait parfois sans complaisance de
l'écrivain pour nous faire mieux
connaître l'homme qu'elles ont aimé et
qui vient de mourir
à travers ce récit on retrouve les
nouvelles les personnages hallucinants
extraordinaire de maupassant
ces nouvelles bâti comme autant de vies
on le sent on le devine à travers comme
immortels comme vivant très belle
écriture parfois un peu longue c'est la
seule réserve que je puis mettra ce
livre mais original et prenante et
surtout très bien et culte
je vous le conseille
on apprend beaucoup sur maupassant mais
notamment sammer le des photos
là c'est sa mère est le défendent bec et
ongles elle elle ne veut pas bon d'abord
parce que il est mort il y a la
prêtresse il y a deux mois et qu'elle
est encore très tourmentée de ce qu'il
est devenu de ce qu'il a vécu avant de
mourir le bourgeonnement voilà il est
mort jeune il avait moins de 45 ans et
pas à cette époque-là pas d'une très
belle mort de celle dont on ne parle il
faut lire ce livre qui vous prend de
bout en bout
c'est un récit et je trouve que
l'imagination de florence disait autour
de cette rencontre est fabuleuse parce
qu'il fallait y penser et les nouvelles
de maupassant
si je puis dire sont toujours
d'actualité merci à nathalie veulent
donc maître de conférences à
l'université de sa côte à côte et à lui
parlé d'un autre monument la littérature
français l'immense patrick modiano lui
tout à fait bernard merci en effet je
vais vous parler du dernier livre de
patrick modiano qui sorti en octobre
certains disent que c'est le mot diano
millésime 2010 9
alors c'est vrai qu'on attend toujours
le dernier mot diano un peu comme on
attend le dernier woody allen ans et ça
fait partie de ces livres qu'on vient
lire pas tellement pour être surpris je
crois mais pour retrouver là la petite
musique le talent de l'auteur d'un peu
de retrouver alors patrick modiano là
encore va nous ramener à son sillon
familier en les souvenirs l'enfance
l'absence ou si paris est comme dans
d'autres livres il s'agit de retrouver
la trace de quelqu'un alors on a un
personnage qui s'appelle jean ébène qui
employé dans une agence de détectives et
qui enquête sur une femme c'est une
certaine joël lefevre pardon de noël
lefèvre qui a disparu qui s'est évaporé
alors on retrouve comme ça comme dans
tous les romans de modiano des
personnages qui sont complètement il va
pour est floue évanescent
il ya cette atmosphère très brumeuse que
réussi à faire transparaître modiano et
on est dans une sorte de filature de de
l'invisible et le narrateur nous nous
entraîne et bien dans l'est dans le
labyrinthe des rues des rues mais aussi
de sa mémoire et alors on va errer on va
arpenter les rues de paris
essentiellement le 15e arrondissement le
quartier de l'opéra aussi est dans la
dernière partie du livre on arrive à
rome qui est comme on lit dans dans le
livre la ville de l'oubli parce que
c'est en effet un livre sur l'oubli sûr
n'oubliez sur les souvenirs et alors le
livre son titre c'est encre sympathique
1 et cette encre sympathique qu'est ce
que c'est c'est une encre invisible qui
noircit au gré de l'action d'une
substance déterminée et c'est la même
chose que l'encré sympathique les
souvenirs eh bien parfois une émergent
ils en reviennent à la surface
alors voilà tout ça ça donne là la
cartographie signé modiano ans avec
l'interpénétration du réel et de
l'imaginaire c'est moi diane s60 voilà
nobel de littérature grand prix de la
dga française prix goncourt
vous savez qu'il était en classe modiano
non avec avec balkany et sardou 99
au collège du mont salle qui n'existe
plus mais voilà ils ont fait toute leur
scolarité ensemble des fortunes diverses
c'est amusant d imaginer tous les trois
un quatrième essai plus qu'elle est 4e
de la borne d'un quatrième larron mère
inquiète aussi aussi assez connu quel
beau merci bien nous en passer par là
claire belles dents donc qu'est
comédiennes chanteuses de talent et qui
va nous parler de johnatan les vics
tonnes les goélands dans une grande
parabole
il ya eu un film d'ailleurs oui oui
parce que richard bach donc l'auteur est
aussi réalisateur du film
voilà donc johnatan des vics tonnes le
goéland aurait pu s'appeler un goéland
pas comme les autres
c'est un livre philosophique c'est un
livre qui fait réfléchir
effectivement je tâtonne et très
différents des siens parce que les siens
n'ont qu'un but dans la vie c'est se
nourrir en ne fournissant que un minimum
d'effort et lui il ne trouve de goût à
la vie que en volant toujours plus vite
toujours plus haut alors il est tout à
fait incompris des siens et donc il
essaie de le décourager
donc il fait un petit peu marche arrière
et puis en fin de compte dont il a
tellement envie de voler que eh bien ils
résistent et il est rejeté des siens il
est banni et il s'en va et il a le
courage de partir seul
donc il ne choisit pas un chemin facile
richard bach et pilotant donc américaine
en ce mois là et donc c'était pas un
hasard s'il a choisi un goéland pour
comme narrateur de ce livre une part
active
le livre a été refusée par dix-huit
grands éditeurs avant d'être édité
le sport donc celui ferme et de
s'interroger comment agir seul face à
tous les autres
comment résister au chantage affectif
comment délester ses bagages pour
pouvoir grandir
moi c'est des questions qu'on se pose en
lecture de ce livre c'est une leçon de
courage en ce livre ça permet
d'envisager sa vie avec d'autres
couleurs avec d'autres perspectives de
multiples perspectives et je dirais pour
conclure que c'est un livre qui permet
de s'envoler
merci clair pour ce livre culte et donc
par les eaux sales de la zone i qui
éditeurs et qui va nous parler d'un
polar je crois on n'est jamais mieux
servi que par soi même donc un polar que
j'ai édité jackpot c'est particulier
parce que c'est pas exactement un peu
lancé une collection s'appelle vraiment
pas policier mais presque ça pourrait
donner ce qu'on appelle de la
littérature blanche mais en mettant
roman policier mais presque j'assure le
lecteur qui est une véritable histoire
connaît un début un milieu et une fin
c'est pas de l'auto-fiction la française
que je que je déteste
donc là c'est une histoire ça commence
un peu comme un un livre de gilbert
cesbron que les plus anciens à coller ce
qui était très bien et c'est l'histoire
d'un petit fonctionnaire obscures
de la mairie de paris qui vit toute
chasse de façon assez médiocre et puis
tout d'un coup son son banquier lui dit
mais vous avez mis quatre vingt mille
euros de côté depuis dix ans que
travaillé à la mairie de paris vous
dépensez rien vu dans une chambre de
bonne achetez donc un petit appartement
il va acheter une chambre de bonne et
tombe sous le charme d'un d'un marchand
de biens franco chinois qui va l'emmener
dans une quête immobilier absolument
insensé et très fructueuse alors ça
c'est début du livre il fait fortune peu
à peu et puis il se focalise uniquement
sur son empire immobilier
et puis il ya quand même un tout petit
côté paula parce qu'à un moment il ya
une dispute on essaie de lui enlever son
fils et une femme alors ils sont dans le
bâtiment et il se débarrasse de cette
pauvre femme en la mettant sous une
chape de béton et puis tout se passe
bien 10 ans passe encore mais au bout de
dix ans ils revendent l'appartement ils
revendent le truc et les gens font des
travaux ils découvrent ils découvrent le
cadavre et là ils vont la prison de la
santé sont ils sont embastillés et comme
c'est des génies de l'immobilier
commencent à retaper la prison de la
santé et à dire ou là mais c'est c'est
totalement insalubre
c'est curieux cet endroit puis à des
gens bizarres il ya des gens radicaliser
et c'est alors il commence à refaire la
prison un peu rééduquer des prisonniers
lutter contre les rats et il arrive à
dérider radicaliser des prisonniers et
du coup ça remonte jusqu'aux oreilles de
l'elysée elysée on dit bah tiens c'est
une bonne idée ils sont pas mal ces deux
gars là parce qu'il était avec son homme
de main sont en prison et finalement ils
vont avoir le droit de quitter la prison
de temps en temps pour aller faire
exploser des terroristes un peu dans le
monde entier pour essayer de
contrebalancer le
la fcc et ses sbires alors si vous ne
sorte de fable bien évidemment l'idée
pas dire qu'il faut aller faire sauter
tout le monde mais c'est extrêmement
amusant ses truculents c'est très gonflé
c'est politiquement incorrect c'est
écrit par un ancien professeur de philo
enfin anciens se voit que tu n'existes
qui n'exerce plus il est toujours devoir
de philo n'a toujours toutes ses
connaissances et spécialistes aussi du
transsibérien
donc on voyage et on s'amuse et puis on
réfléchit beaucoup parce que c'est
extrêmement intéressant
merci jean soir alors pour terminer je
voudrais vous parler de patrice
franceschi donc qui sera le président
d'honneur du salon d'elancourt le
dimanche 24 novembre
patrice pons et si on a parlé beaucoup
actuellement pour son combat en faveur
des kurdes depuis des années il est allé
sur le terrain
il a même pris la kalachnikov contre les
d'âge tout ça c'est il avait fait la
même chose en afghanistan contre l'armée
soviétique
c'est quelqu'un d'exceptionnel et un
très grand écrivain il est poète aussi
il a fait des recueils fantastique où
l'on coud et ça il est romancier auteur
de récits et c'est un très grand
nouvelliste il a eu le prix goncourt de
la nouvelle en 2015 pour première
personne du singulier ce n'est pas un
hasard
et là ils ressortent un recueil de
nouvelles qui s'appelle le chemin de la
mer on retrouve le capitaine du trois
mâts la boudeuse
alors là c'est une des nouvelles très
bien fait beaucoup d'imagination on me
raconte c'est un voyageur qui traversent
toujours les mêmes il a il retrouve les
mêmes jours et il trouve le salut dans
la mer il ya aussi l'histoire d'un homme
de petite taille qui comédien dans une
pièce de théâtre qui doit toujours dire
la même réplique et injuria il ya un
parterre exceptionnels là il ya le roi
est tout il va sortir de la norme il va
faire quelque chose d'extraordinaire
c'est vraiment des nouvelles très bien
écrite
patrice franceschi ont plus d'un
humaniste un explorateur
c'est un très très grand écrivain et il
restera dans l'histoire
dans l'est dans la lignée des cendres
arc s l et s avance de 24 novembre
elle encourt merci
[Musique]